حتى الان شعارات التي كانوا يهتفون بها هم
كانوا يقولون قاتل قاتل كانوا يهتفون بان
هذا الشخص هو قاتل لكن على العموم المنطقه
هي كبيره ولديها فيها تفرعات كبيره جدا
لذلك الشرطه تغلق في كافه المداخل وربما
هذه المواجهات التي تجري في موقع ليس بعيد
عني لكنها في محيط هذه المنطقه اريد
ان اريد الداخليه قال ان هذا الشخص البالغ
من العمر 69 عاما كان موظفا لدى شركه همم
لدى الخطوط الحديديه الفرنسيه وكان سائقه
قطار وهو همم
نحن نعلم اليوم ان هناك اضرابات كبيره جدا
في قطاع النقل خصوصا السكك الحديديه في
فرنسا اذا ربما تكون المساله ايضا متعلقه
دي همم بوضع اقتصادي لهذا الشخص على العلم
انه ايضا هجم في العام الماضي مركزا ل- اا
اللاجئين همم
ويحاكم من اجل من اجل هذا الهجوم لكن
اشير فادي الى ما شاهدناه قبل قليل اصابه
يبدو في صفوف قوات الامن هناك ايضا اغلاق
لطريق من خلال
حريق يقطع الطريق ربما امام تحرك لاي من
القوات الامنيه مواجهه شرسه في ما يبدو
همم المتظاهرون يرشقون كانوا الشرطه
والقوات الامنيه بما توفر لديهم هذا الغضب
من الشرطه هو باعتبار بانها تراهت في
التعاطي مع هذا الملف الامني المهم انه
الموضوع مجرد تعبير
[موسيقى]
يجوز الوجهان لان الشرطه وكما نعلم ان
الجاني لديه سوابق في مهاجمه الاجانب
وخصوصا الاجئين والمهاجرين همم لذلك هذه
هذا الغضب ربما يكون في هذا السياق لانهم
يعتبرون ان الشرطه لم لم يكن عليها ان
يتجول بحريه ومعه سلاح ايضا اليوم يعني
بعد كل الهجمات الارهابيه التي ضربت فرنسا
والوضع الامني الذي تم تشديده وعدد كبير
من الشرطه والتعزيزات الامنيه التي تذوب
الشوارع الشوارع العاصمه كل يوم هذا يطرح
تساؤل كيف تمكن هذا الشخص من الوصول الى
هذه المنطقه وبحوزته هذا هذا السلاح الذي